the in mainstream media in typical
fashion they focused on the real threat
Islamophobia salon.com ran this headline
quote after the New York City terror
attack Fox News leans into nationalism
and Islamophobia North Country Public
Radio says this headline art as a way to
resist negative images and Islamophobia
splinter News did this NBC News did this
from NBC Muslim Americans brace for
backlash after New York attack they're
bracing that's the story not the attack
that just happened but the bracing
that's going to happen for the
inevitable backlash that inevitably
never happens
anchors and writers from MSNBC Teen
Vogue The Guardian on and on and on used
the same as lame' phobia line New York
Times early reporting on the attack
refused to report the language properly
they wouldn't do it they would not use
the phrase Allahu Akbar which is the war
cry that the terrorists shouted when he
had finished his attack instead The
Times use the phrase god is great which
is an okay sort of mistranslation of
that phrase into English their News
Alert headline read the motorist yelled
god is great in Arabic officials said
CNN did exactly the same thing their
lower third reporting on the attack said
suspect was yelling god is great in
Arabic The Associated Press did this in
April when they reported the Muslim
terrorists yelled god is great best of
all here is former journalist Jake
Tapper's take on the jihadi battlecry
he heard this driver saying yelling
Allahu Akbar Allah Akbar during this
incident which is now leading
authorities to believe that this is as a
result that this is now a terrorism case
and I'm just getting an update now the
FBI is taking over this case because it
appears now that this is terrorism the
Arabic chanda Allah Akbar god is great
sometimes I said under the most
beautiful of circumstances and too often
we hear of it between being said in
moments like this it's beautiful the
most beautiful of circumstances that's
the story right that's the first thing
you should say when reacting to the bad
news the terrorists screamed a beautiful
phrase that has also denoted Muslim holy
war for 14th centuries what'd he look
he's
said that it was used in bad
circumstances too but the first thing
that we should note the important point
here is that the phrase is also used in
nice circumstances sometimes and sure
that might be true contrary to popular
belief the term Allahu Akbar does not
appear in the Quran in the Muslim holy
book rather it appears in the hadith
which reports the actions and sayings of
Muhammad it also doesn't mean God is
great it means God is greater or God is
greatest probably more precisely
translated and sure it's a phrase used
in times of joy it's used in times of
distress joy birth death holy festivals
on and on sort of misses the point
doesn't because allahu akbar is the
ubiquitous battle cry of muslim
terrorists that we've seen for decades
and decades in the notes of the
terrorists who flew the planes on
September 11th we're talking about a
Muslim terrorist attack here here is a
relevant appearance of the phrase Allahu
Akbar in the hadith quote the Prophet
set out for Khaybar and reached it at
night he used not to attack if he
reached the people at night till the day
broke so when the day dawned the Jews
came out with their bags and spades when
they saw the Prophet they said Muhammad
and his army the Prophet said Allahu
Akbar and Khaybar is ruined for whenever
we approach a nation it has tan enemy to
fight then it will be a miserable
morning for those who have been warned
end quote
now Andrew Clavin who never gets into
Twitter spats despite my telling him how
fun they are
he pointed this out to Jake Tapper on
Twitter he pointed out to Tapper that he
was basically saying there are good
people on both sides aren't there folks
the thing that the mainstream media
excoriated Trump for saying in the wake
of charlottesville Tapper defended his
statement that he went further any
accused drew of lying so so drew
responded he said all sorts of things
can be said at weddings and births
it's an inane point that purposely begs
the question the nature of our enemy
Tapper unhinge idli and bizarrely
continued to call Andrew Klavan a liar
but of course he provided no evidence
for that accusation because Jake Tapper
is a Democrat hack who plays a
journalist on a fictional television
program this does however make clear a
key factor in the mainstream media's
recent self-immolation which is their
abusive language
we're living in an age marked defined by
language that is not clear and direct
but of euphemisms words that make harsh
things see mild bad truths appear good
and they make clear events seem obscure
Democrats just last week ran an ad
against Virginia gubernatorial candidate
at Gillespie depicting a Republican
truck mowing down children of ethnic
minority here it is
is this what Donald Trump and Ed
Gillespie mean by the American dream
Latino Victory Fund paid for and is
responsible for the content of this
advertisement that's the threat huh
that's what we're worried about we're
worried about Tea Partiers we're
worrying about the Gadsden flag flying
on a truck that's not today's Michael
we're gonna see an increase on the
cooldown period of trucks that's that's
right it you know that's what we're
that's what we're seeing right that's
before our eyes
not quite the American people aren't
stupid
we know that the terrorists didn't
scream god is great we know what war
looks like we know what peace looks like
we know which ideas and vessels for
those ideas threaten our lives and our
civilization the more the mainstream
media insists that our eyes are lying
the less credibility they'll have